alors que les relations entre la russie
et l'occident sont au plus bas l'amitié
entre moscou et la chine ne cesse de se
renforcer et les jeux olympiques d'hiver
de pékin illustrent à merveille vladimir
poutine fait ainsi partie des quelques
30 dirigeants mondiaux présents à cette
cérémonie d'ouverture de l'olympiade
hors de question pour lui de se rallier
aux chancelleries occidentales qui à
l'instar de washington londres et
canberra ont boycotté l'événement
prétextant la persécution de la minorité
musulmane ouïghoure dans lux indian dans
le nord ouest de la chine un boycott
qu'avec condamné vladimir poutine lors
de sa conférence de presse annuelle le
23 décembre dernier
c'est une politique erronée d'essayer
d'utiliser le sport pour résoudre
certaines questions politiques à courte
vue ils ne peuvent pas freiner le
développement de la chine ils doivent
enfin en prendre conscience ils ne sont
pas capables de le contenir aujourd'hui
en termes de parité de pouvoir d'achat
l'économie de la chine est déjà plus
grande que celle des états unis
l'ouverture des jo s'est également prêté
un sommet chine russie le premier tête à
tête en personne des deux chefs d'état
en près de deux ans coronavirus oblige
mais leur 38e rencontre depuis 2013 un
rendez-vous que xi jinping avait dit
attendre avec impatience lors d'un appel
vidéo avec celui qu'elle considère comme
un ami à cette même occasion en décembre
dernier vladimir poutine avait
d'ailleurs qualifié les relations
russo-chinoises je cite deux modèles
véritable de la coopération
interétatique au 21e siècle
un nouveau modèle de coopération s'est
formé entre nos pays qui se base entre
autres sur des fondements telles que la
non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures il au respect des intérêts
de chacun la volonté de faire de notre
frontière commune une ceinture de paix
et de bon voisinage les liens
commerciaux et économiques se renforcent
également entre janvier et novembre de
cette année les échanges ont connu une
croissance de 31% allant jusqu'à 123
milliards de dollars ainsi nous avons
déjà battu les records prépandémique de
outre leurs échanges commerciaux au beau
fixe pékin et moscou partage aussi des
approches communes à l'égard de nombreux
dossiers internationaux y compris la
crise en ukraine ce 4 février les deux
états ont ainsi publié un communiqué
dans lequel ils se disent je cite opposé
à tout élargissement futur de l'otan et
appelle l'alliance atlantique à
respecter la souveraineté la sécurité et
les intérêts des autres pays la chine et
la russie semble avoir bien compris que
l'union faisait la force face à
l'occident les états unis avec leurs
alliés occidentaux exerce une pression
tous azimuts sur la chine et la russie
en mettant en place le principe de
juridiction extraterritoriale et en
imposant de façon arbitraire des
sanctions contre des institutions
gouvernementales
établissements et personnels des deux
pays afin de freiner leur développement
pour répondre à cette hégémonie non
déguisé et à la politique de la force
nous devons continuer à approfondir
notre coopération stratégique en nous
tenant au coude à coude à la renforcer
sur le plan pratique et dans différentes
directions pour pouvoir faire face et
résister de façon efficace à la double
dissuasion pratiqué par les états unis
et l'occident rien ne renforce plus
l'amitié car ennemi commun écrivait
l'auteur irlandais franck fortement à
trop vouloir faire pression sur moscou
et pékin et washington et l'otan devrait
peut être prendre garde à ne pas avoir
les yeux plus gros que le ventre